So, what would happen if you consumed
just two tablespoons of extra [snorts]
virgin olive oil every single day?
That's the topic for today. There's a
lot of amazing things in olive oil that
people have no clue. And there's a
couple ways you can take it. I put it on
my salad. And this is my I don't know if
you can see this right here. This is my
olive oil right here. Okay. I use a very
specific type because it's the real
stuff. I've been to uh the farm in Italy
where they grow these olives. It's
called Vtori Sanm Michelle Attorii.
Okay. Uh but anyway, um unfortunately, a
lot of the olive oil out there is fake.
And I had no idea of fake versus real
for many, many years and probably uh
until five years ago uh when I actually
tasted real extravirgin olive oil and
I'm like, "Wow, this is amazing." Before
I was consuming this fake olive oil that
was bland. It didn't really have any
taste. It didn't have that uh peppery
grass like taste and it didn't irritate
the back of my throat. Those are just
indicators you have the real thing
because unfortunately they sometimes
dilute olive oil with other oils like
soy or canola. So they're trying to
clean that up right now. But it was
quite amazing when I went to this farm
where they created this olive oil. Uh, I
had a chance to check the soil and check
the microbes which are off the chart.
Also, the care involved in making this
product was just way over the top. I
mean, this goes way beyond just organic.
Now, I don't get any kickbacks from this
company, but I will say when I find a
good product, I definitely will let
people know about it. So, you can either
add it to your salad uh with balsamic
vinegarette or apple cider vinegar. I
put some lemon on my salad. I put sea
salt or you can just take two
tablespoons of this oil every day. It's
a pure fat, so it's not going to spike
insulin. So, let me just go through some
of the compounds in olive oil, okay? And
I'm not going to give you the long names
because every time I do that, I tend to
put people to sleep. So, I'll just bring
it up on the slide and I'll go through
the different effects that can be
created. So this first phytonutrient has
some pretty powerful cardoprotective
properties. Okay, giving you significant
blood pressure lowering effects. You
have two different types of blood
pressure. You have primary and
secondary. Another name for primary is
called essential. So essential
hypertension. And what's interesting
about that is that it doesn't have a
cause. They don't know what the cause
is. And that's 95%
of all the blood pressure problems out
there. They don't know what the cause
is. Of course, we have all sorts of
medications to help you in the meantime
until we find a cause. And since we're
on the topic of this, you might also
want to add vitamin D and more potassium
as well as lowering your sugar because
when you have insulin resistance, you
can make the arteries really, really
hardened and your blood pressure will go
up. But the point is that extravirgin
olive oil can help you. They even make
this special point. If you're on
medication and you're taking olive oil
at the same time, your blood pressure
could come down too low. I mean, why
wouldn't you want something without side
effects to lower your blood pressure? I
mean, the solution is just to take less
medication, right? Some other benefits
include anti-cancer.
It also protects the hypothalamus and
another part of your brain called the
substantiate which has everything
to do about dopamine and if you have a
problem with that part of your brain you
can end up with Parkinson's. So olive
oil protects the brain and has
neuroprotective properties. And another
really important thing about um olive
oil is it's very anti-inflammatory.
There's a lot of things in extra virgin
olive oil that help with inflammation
and pain. So, let's move on to the next
uh phytonutrient. This one again gives
you anti-inflammatory benefits. It can
act as an analesic to help with pain. It
has antimicrobial effects and also it
can help support the beta cell, the
pancreas, which has everything to do
with helping your blood sugars and um
also with helping lowering insulin.
because the beta cell makes insulin. All
right. In this next compound, there's
anti-cancer properties as well as
anti-arthritic
benefits. And then in these last three
phytonutrients, which are steriles, a
sterile is a compound that's very
similar to cholesterol and also similar
to steroids. And so in this first
compound, there's benefits with uh
benign prostatic hypertrophy. If you get
this enlarged prostate, um, extra-virgin
olive oil can help you. This
phytonutrient also helps you balance
cholesterol, specifically LDL, and I'm
talking about the small dense particles.
Okay? And then we get another
phytonutrient, which is another sterile,
which is anti-inflammatory and also that
can benefit your LDL. And then there's
another sterile which can also help with
your LDL. So there are a lot of
different phytonutrients. I just covered
only six of them, but there are hundreds
of naturally occurring compounds with
all sorts of very cool effects. There's
also, by the way, a good amount of
vitamin E in extravirgin olive oil. So,
I hope in this video I convinced you to
start using more olive oil on a regular
basis. It can really help you. And if
you haven't seen this video on olive
oil, you definitely want to check it
out. I put it up right here. I was
talking with someone uh about their
inflammation in their body recently.
They were on ibuprofen and they wanted
to know is there any natural ibuprofen
out there and that's the basis of this
video. Extra virgin olive oil. You're
going to have to find the real stuff,
but there's some great data. I'll put
the link down below that demonstrates
that extravirgin olive oil, specifically
this chemical called alleanthal. And
this natural chemical in extravirgin
olive oil has a potential to mimic the
effects of ibuprofen. And this natural
anti-inflammatory
chemical in extravirgin olive oil gives
you that strong stinging sensation in
the back of your throat. Okay? And if
you don't get that sensation when you're
consuming olive oil, chances are uh you
don't have the authentic extravirgin
olive oil that you should be using
because there's so many versions that
are fake out there, especially in the
US. Now, the biochemical effect that
this creates is the inhibition or
something that inhibits
COX one and COX 2 enzymes. Those are the
enzymes that are creating inflammation.
So, when you inhibit those enzymes, you
get rid of inflammation. And this
chemical in olive oil can mimic
ibuprofen, which is very, very cool. Of
course, check with your doctor before
coming off any medications. Now, you
would have to consume 50 milligrams.
That's a little more than 1 and a2
ounces. You can easily put that on your
salad every day. And you'll get between
60 to 90% absorption, which comes out to
about 9 millig. And I would recommend
doing that every day if you have a
tendency to get inflammation. And of
course, as a side note, if you're
getting inflammation, we know you
probably have too many carbs in your
diet. And if you're new to my channel,
click the link down below to get the
exact diet you need to be on. Now, one
last thing about this natural compound.
It can help you reduce the formation of
beta amaloids. That's the plaquing that
develops when you have Alzheimer's. And
this compound has anti-cancer effects in
a variety of cancers while leaving your
normal cells alone. Okay? So, it's very
selective in targeting cancer cells but
not your normal cells. And the way they
do it is they target something in the
cancer cells called the lo, which is the
garbage disposal. And they have enzymes
to break that down. So, this enzyme
prevents the breakdown of waste in a
cancer cells. So the cancer cell dies
within 30 minutes, not to mention other
effects that cause the cancer cells to
commit suicide. That's called apoptosis.
So anyway, if you have the real
extravirgin olive oil and you're putting
it on your salad every day, it could
have some really cool uh effects that
can help potentially reduce even the
formation of cancer.
Hey, before you go, if you're benefiting
from any of my content, I would love to
hear about your success story. Please
share it in the link down below.